president trump was just caught on a
hidden camera speaking to
uh
a you know very very famous golf star so
this is not a high-level government
meeting he's just talking to a buddy of
his and the conversation was secretly
recorded he is describing how he dealt
with vladimir putin
you know
he was a friend of mine i got along with
him i say vladimir if you're doing we're
hitting moscow i said we're going to hit
moscow and he sort of believed me like 5
percent that's all you need he never did
it during my time john you know no
you're all talking about it no he's
funny
during the last four years because he
knew he couldn't it's funny how she
didn't bother you either
yeah no she didn't bother me i told him
the same thing
that'll be next yeah you know that's
going to be next taiwan will be next
year you won't have any computer chips
they'll blow them off the face of the
air
so this is a casual conversation about
all the bumbles from joe biden
the most interesting part to me is that
five to ten percent
he says look putin i'm gonna hit moscow
and he believed me he believed me five
to ten percent which is enough
right trump is not boasting here that he
completely 100 convinced putin that he
would hit moscow
in the event of an invasion of ukraine
he's not even saying
that he 100 wasn't going to do it
he's saying
all i had to do was convince putin that
there was a five to ten percent chance
that i would bomb moscow
the lesson here is
unpredictability
is an extremely powerful political asset
and the problem one of the biggest
problems right now with the current
occupant of the oval office is he is 100
completely predictable
it's not even the specific policies all
of which are terrible but it's just that
we know exactly what he's going to do
all the time and that gives our foreign
adversaries a huge advantage because
they can plan ahead
and they can plan not just an invasion
of a country but they can plan four or
five steps ahead because they know that
all biden is going to do is the usual
classical typical establishment
playbook
trump was not like that
i don't think people believed that it
was very likely that trump would
go in and
bomb moscow
go in and invade some country he ran as
a fairly anti-war candidate
but they believed there was a chance
every so often he'd go take out an
iranian general
out of the blue and even a lot of the
establishment didn't like that he did
that every so often he dropped the
mother of all bombs on a country and
just you didn't
and he tried to minimize deaths in that
but he would just he would do
wild things he would tweet out hey i've
got a bigger nuclear button than yours
kim jong-un and my button's bigger and
it works
you think the guy's threatening world
war three
that unpredictable you just need that
little bit five to ten percent it's true
in show business you don't tune into
shows
where you know exactly word for word on
every single issue what some guy is
going to say
you don't do it
even if you generally agree with the guy
because you you
want there to be some kind of tension
some unpredictability something that you
could learn
something that he knows that you don't
know
same is true
in politics much ironic people are
making fun of this clip unironically
this is much better statesmanship than
anything we are seeing from biden or the
people around biden i'm so glad you
liked that clip
ring the bell please ring that bell
subscribe and then head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe to the michael knowles show
maybe leave a five star review we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]